identity politics has fractured so much
that these categories of people who are
implicitly pitted against each other for
your sympathy
are infinitely subdividing and that's
the second problem with this way of
looking at the world is that it's
fundamentally adversarial
and so it pits us all against each other
and ironically it pits us all against
each other and the weirdest of spectrums
which is who's more oppressed who has it
the hardest it is about uh it's about
seeing your powerlessness as your power
and that kind of inversion weirdly means
that people who regard themselves as
oppressed have no reason to get
unapppressed that is to solve their
problem
because their problem is their ticket
their gravy train that's where all your
power is